Superhero movies have produced some truly
iconic scenes throughout cinema history.
Who can forget Christopher Reeve's Superman
kneeling before Terence Stamp's General Zod,
prior to breaking his hand and dispatching
the villain?
Or Heath Ledger's Joker asking "Why so serious?"?
Or Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony Stark proclaiming
"I am Iron Man!"?
But, like anything else in life, with the
sublime comes the ridiculous - and the superhero
genre has certainly had its fair share of
ridiculous moments as well.
In this video, we'll take a look at just some
of them.
So watch it, enjoy it, subscribe to our channel,
and join the notification squad to receive
alerts every time we upload new videos!
Here are ten moments in superhero movies that
will make you scratch your head.
Spider-Man 3
2007's Spider-Man 3 was pretty terrible - and
the worst part in the movie was one that definitely
left viewers scratching their head.
After being exposed to the Venom symbiote,
Peter Parker began behaving differently.
His dance in the jazz club was one thing,
but his strut down a busy street en route
to buy a new suit was a different beast entirely.
Parker walked in a rhythmic fashion, eyeing
up women, pointing at them in a suggestive
way, did a little spin, emerged from a store
wearing a new suit, did a little dance, then
went on his merry way.
What on Earth were Sony thinking?!
Superman
In the iconic 1978 Superman movie, Lois Lane
met her demise when aftershocks caused by
Lex Luthor's attempts to create a new land
mass for his real estate resulted in her car
falling down a crevice.
The subsequent actions of the titular superhero
caused fans around the world to scratch their
heads in confusion.
Devastated at Lois' death, Superman flew around
the world at super-speed, rewinding time to
bring her back to life and prevent her death
from happening again.
Superman has been known to pull powers out
of his ass before, but that was just ridiculous.
Superman II
If you thought that last entry was ridiculous,
you haven't heard anything yet, as Superman
pulled yet another crazy power out of his
ass in the 1980 Superman sequel, Superman
II.
It involved Lois Lane again, but the circumstances
were very different.
Lois had discovered that Clark Kent and Superman
were one and the same, but Clark Kent couldn't
have that, so he went to extreme measures
to ensure she forgot that information - he
delivered a big, wet memory-wiping kiss to
his long-time love interest!
That's right, a kiss from Clark Kent wiped
Lois' memory, so she no longer knew he was
Superman.
Makes perfect sense, right?
Ghost Rider: Spirit of Vengeance
Nicolas Cage is bat-shit crazy - everyone
knows that - and he's portrayed a number of
characters who are pretty damned nuts throughout
his acting career.
Cage played Johnny Blaze AKA Ghost Rider in
two different movies based on the character
- and he had a trademark Cage crazy moment
in the second one; 2012's Ghost Rider: Spirit
of Vengeance.
It happened when Blaze was interrogating a
criminal and the Ghost Rider was trying to
come out.
Blaze went crazy and proclaimed that the "thing"
inside him was "SCRAPING AT THE DOOR", leaving
viewers totally puzzled as to what was going
on!
X-Men Origins: Wolverine
X-Men Origins: Wolverine is arguably the worst
movie in the X-Men franchise.
The 2009 offering saw Hugh Jackman's character's
backstory explored and pitted him against
a new foe in the form of Wade Wilson - more
commonly known as Deadpool in the comic books.
But this Deadpool was a far cry from the one
comic book fans know and love - and the moment
that left fans scratching their heads came
when he was unveiled, after having been taken
in by William Stryker and experimented on.
The character - who is known for his smart
mouth - had been silenced, with his mouth
literally sealed shut.
It was a genuinely inexplicable decision on
Fox's part.
X-Men: Days of Future Past
2014's X-Men: Days of Future Past, unlike
the aforementioned Origins: Wolverine, was
one the X-Men franchise's better movies.
It says a lot about Quicksilver, therefore,
that he was the best thing about the movie
- his super-speed scene was awesome, as he
helped the heroic mutants rescue Magneto from
a cell below the Pentgon.
It was, therefore, a head-scratching realisation
when he was subsequently sidelined for the
remainder of the movie.
Not only could he have helped the titular
characters some more in their plight, but
he would also have made the movie so much
cooler with an extended presence.
Iron Man 3
A big part of Tony Stark's character in the
first two Iron Man movies and The Avengers
movie was that he was fated to live with an
arc reactor in his chest for the rest of his
life - a big point was made of the fact that
it couldn't be removied.
However, bizarrely, he had it removed on a
whim at the end of 2013's Iron Man 3.
People will say he used Extremis to survive
the operation to remove the shrapnel from
his heart and the arc reactor itself, but
is Tony Stark really that stupid, given how
volatile he knew it was?
And, more to the point, wouldn't it have been
mentioned in the movie that he had used Extremis,
given that it would be key information?
Very confusing indeed!
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
2016's Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
surprised almost everyone when it killed off
the titular Man of Steel in only Henry Cavill's
second outing as the iconic Kryptonian hero.
It did, however, insinuate that he would return
- which we all know he will - but the manner
in which it did so was bizarre.
Superman's funeral took place after Doomsday
had killed him, and he was placed in a coffin
and buried, but the camera zoomed in on his
coffin to show dirt rising from it, suggesting
he was still alive.
Granted, we all "got" what it meant, but really?
Levitating dirt?
Why was Superman's body causing that to happen?
When you actually think about it, it's really
quite odd.
Fantastic Four: Rise of the Silver Surfer
was the slightly superior 2007 sequel to 2005's
Fantastic Four movie.
That's not to say it was very good though,
because it really wasn't, and part of the
reason for that was its terrible depiction
of the planet-devouring cosmic being known
as Galactus.
When the gigantic antagonist first appeared
on screen in the movie, audiences were aghast
and filled with confusion - he was a gigantic
cloud!
The character's potential to look incredible
in live action was huge, but Fox opted to
turn him into a damn cloud.
It was one of the silliest decisions in comic
book movie history.
Deadpool
You may recall that, at the end of 2016's
brilliant Deadpool movie, the final battle
took place on a helicarrer that was clearly
a homage of sorts to the S.H.I.E.L.D.
helicarriers in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
But there was one particular part of that
battle that really made no sense.
When Negasonic Teenage Warhead accidentally
destroyed the equipment stabilising the helicarrier,
in order to save his girlfriend Vanessa, Deadpool
threw her off the helicarrier inside a glass
chamber.
She fell quite a distance to the ground in
the chamber, but emerged without so much as
a scratch or bruise.
Frankly, she should have died or, at the very
least, been severely injured by the fall.
Thanks for watching our video about ten moments
in superhero movies that will make you scratch
your head.
Which other superhero movie moments left you
wondering what the hell was going on?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.